AOC was supposed to be this Insurgent
character who was coming into the
Democrat Party and being like I am here
for young people and we don't like the
machine and now she's like woo Pentagon
we're in this together
so you know yeah they're on the same
team it's it's Captain America we came
together to be to be fair Captain
America was a DOD project
yeah the US government no that is true
no I know that's that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying it's how it gets
into their heads right
it's very industrial military complexes
gotta let it go and you're right no but
here's a fun fact you know so before uh
World War II superheroes usually just
kind of like solved problems in their
own communities in the comics like they
would beat someone up who was doing bad
things in their cities and then it was
during World War II that they started
making all the comics about like the
superheroes saving the world